nous sommes évidemment très préoccupé
par ces résultats c'est une prise de
conscience aujourd'hui pour le spvm un
premier regard indépendant et
scientifique sur la discrimination au
sein du corps de police et nos analyses
révèlent des disparités suffisamment
considérable pour suggérer la présence
de billes et systémique inverse certains
groupes racisés plus précisément selon
le rapport des chercheurs les
autochtones et les noirs à montréal ont
quatre à cinq fois plus de chances de se
faire interpeller par la police que les
personnes blanches alors que les arabes
eux sont deux fois plus à risque de
subir le même sort
moi je vous dis qu'on n'a pas de
policiers restés sont des policiers qui
sont des citoyens nécessairement on
didier le directeur du spvm défend ses
agents mais promet des mesures pour
régler le problème dès le printemps il
compte par exemple mettre en place une
politique pour mieux encadrer les
interpellations
une mesure qui est loin de convaincre
tout le monde savary un chargé 1er mai
doit fonctionner les gens qui combine
des oeuvres est justement quand la
communauté
il doit y avoir une reddition de comptes
il doit y avoir une imputabilité selon
cette sociologue le problème de
profilage racial ou spvm est connu
depuis plus de dix ans ce doit être
tolérance zéro elles demandent entre
autres plus d'agents issus des minorités
visibles dans la police c'est quel
message on lance finalement ces jeunes
nés ici
enfin de la loi 101 deuxième troisième
génération dans certains cas c'est qu'on
leur dit finalement vous n'avez pas
votre place dans l'espace public
ces données ne représente en rien la
ville que l'on veut la mairesse s'est
dit choqué et l'accuse les
administrations précédentes de ne pas
avoir pris le problème au sérieux
elle demande elle aussi plus de
policiers autochtones noirs et arabes
par exemple ça stagne depuis dix ans ça
suffit il faut qu'on a une meilleure
représentation au sein du s p viable
selon le dernier rapport annuel du spvm
moins de 10% des policiers proviennent
de communautés autochtones ou de
minorités visibles alors qu'ils comptent
pour près d'un tiers de la population
montréalaise ici sébastien desrosiers
radio canada morrell